hey friends and welcome back to Deep
dive the podcast where it's my immense
pleasure to sit down with authors and
entrepreneurs and academics and creators
and other inspiring people and we find
out how they got to where they are and
the strategies and tools we can learn
from them to help build a life that we
love today we are going to be wrapping
up season 7 of the podcast firstly I
want to say a massive thank you to
everyone who has watched or listened to
the podcast on any platform YouTube
Spotify snipped whatever platform you're
using and very excitingly we've hit
400,000 subscribers on the Deep dive
with Ali abdal YouTube channel which is
absolutely sick and we've had some
incredible guests over the last few
months we've had billionaire CEOs world
famous athletes mental health experts
and Brilliant professors and we've
talked about building businesses
becoming creators managing the risks
from Ai and leveling up our mindset and
our life so today I'm going to be
sharing six of the best mindset shifts
from the past season which will help
make 2024 the best year of your life
we're going to hear from mindset expert
and psychiatrist Professor Steve Peters
psychologist Dr Julie Smith awardwinning
entrepreneur jod cook business Expert
Chris Ducker world champion rugby player
Dan Carter and public speaking coach
alienor Hunter and I hope you enjoy this
little Roundup episode your book The
Chim Paradox is absolutely like world
famous
um I wonder if we can if I can ask you
what's the what's the Mind model that
you introduced in the book and then
we'll kind of going back yeah to the
1990s what happened is um there was an
epiphany moment and it was with a
particular patient so I won't go into
the great detail but just to say that I
was Able by just asking the right
questions to talk to what I thought was
a very sensible person and then suddenly
someone who didn't seem sensible at all
and was very emotional and pretty
catastrophic in thinking so I started
looking at what do because we' now got
functional MRI scanners what does the
the research show us on this and I
started realizing that if we scan
somebody's brain and they were talking
as what I'd called a human being they
were rational they were logical so I'm
going to simplify the Neuroscience
because I realized a lot of listeners
are not neuroscientists we looked at the
top part of your head the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex seem to be leading on
this and this we know is where executive
functioning takes place so in essence if
you put your oxygen supply in that part
of your brain you're going to think and
work in a certain way yeah you look for
facts logic but there's a more to it
that hit me that part of the brain works
with acceptance and starts saying it is
what it is that part of the brain looks
for
Solutions as opposed to when I started
moving the patient by asking emotive
questions so things that would make them
upset or more emotional if you look at
functional scanners what'll happen
they'll go to the orbit of frontal
cortex just above your eyes and now they
start acting in a very strange way they
wouldn't work with facts at all in fact
they'd have great difficulty accepting
them so what they do is go on feelings
I'm not saying they're wrong and
intuition and they'll work with those
and they won't understand facts it's
almost like facts are not part of the
vocabulary so what you've got to I
started to see is I've got two people in
the room or two brains in the room so
then I start looking and think well how
can I understand this better and that
became two systems so then I looked and
I thought you see classic Connections in
the brain so when the orbit of frontal
works it pulls on things like the
amygdala heavily um all of the brain to
me is like an orchestra so both of these
systems pull on the brain but they
select certain of the instruments and
the orbit frontal selects feelings past
experience emotion it works on trigger
points it works on behaviors so this is
behavioral therapies coming in and then
I looked at the dorsal lateral areas and
they don't work with behaviors they work
with rationality and thinking so your
cognitive therapies are coming
in nice and that I thought oh this is
really good but there's more to the
brain than that so in the
center uh you've got all this other sort
of instruments playing away they're not
the lead instruments they're not the
orchestral conductors which is what
these two other parts are they're the
thinkers but they actually contribute
heavily so I started seeing that as
being a
computer so what I'd got is the center
of the brain was a computer advising but
it does more than advise we may get to
this uh it actually takes over so there
was a paradox that when you imprint to
belief in that computer the two thinkers
are going to be the decision makers y
have to listen to that they can't go
against it okay so for example if you
had a belief that this building was on
sound and the roof is about to collapse
then whether you think emotionally or
rationally you have to get out of the
building yeah you know so the center of
your brain it was crucial that it seemed
blank at
Birth part from instincts and drives
it's blank belief systems start coming
in we work them out from being taught or
experience so I started think we can
alter that and that would alter whether
you left the building or not on your
belief yeah so this all got complicated
as he's doing and I thought this got to
be made simple now I teach at Sheffield
medical school and teaching medical
students um they like things simple and
practical as I do and I'm thinking these
are doctors to be and they're not going
to be neuroscientists they're going to
be many of them GPS and other careers in
medicine but they want understanding of
what the patients are thinking how they
they act and how they can work with that
and so I then had another Epiphany MH I
started looking at people and thinking
when they're irrational they look just
like
chimpanzees I looked at chimpanzees and
thought they have a society which is
very similar not everything is is in
line but I started speaking to the homy
Specialists people who knew the aps but
more important the ones were the
neuroscientists looking at the APS and
at that point I was was told and I
believe them the chimpanzee and the
human have the same system in their
brain when we reacting emotionally so
but the other rapes don't so we think in
a certain way now this has been
published 20 years on in 2018 they
published this to say the other great
tapes the gorilla rang a Tang bonobo
they don't think like humans and
chimpanzees but we are so close that we
say this is our nearest relative y
because we think the way they think
genetically it's not our nearest
relative the bonobos got more Je
um so I just coined the phrase I said to
the students if I said you had a little
Chimp in your head and when you're in
this part of your brain that's the chimp
brain they loved it it was simple so
when you become irrational or your mind
takes over that part of your brain works
with trigger points behaviors is
impulsive catastrophic it's a defense
system yep whereas when you move to the
dorsal lateral areas you're in human
mode now it's you but what was
intriguing is I was getting this with
patients and then there was this moment
for again for me an epiphany probably
around just the late
90s there was no control over the orbit
of frontal it was very fast moving and
it's a reactive system and it's inbuilt
and you're given it and when you look at
the development of the brain it has a
head start in the fetus so it's all
already operating in fetal life and it
keeps going right through yep all of our
life whereas the human part as I'm
calling it didn't operate so we come
late to the party so I started then
looking at Child Development and I found
that it's obvious it became blatant that
children around two or three start
saying why and the do the lateral areas
are coming in with reasoning before that
they don't ask it's behavioral y so for
example if you want to help a child
that's distressed distract it yeah you
know and we know that works best don't
reason with it because you can't reason
so so so this all started coming
together and I thought I've got to keep
it simple so the students helped me they
wouldn't let me go complex so they said
right you've got a human brain which is
you have you are in control of that and
that's logic rational calm and solution
finding you got a chimp pray in which
you've been given at Birth yep and
that's why at the beginning of this I
said that's your mind it's a machine you
don't have a say in it research shows
that for most of us we're on the
neurotic type Spectrum our chimp system
is highly strong and it's quite reactive
and impulsive but there's a spectrum
some people have very quiescent calm
chimps yeah uh and I always say to
people if you're got a calm chimp it may
seem an advantage but actually in the
long run it's a negative because it's
meant to be highly reactive it's meant
to give you warning of danger yeah uh
and that going back to your point about
um Sports people or or anybody it can be
your best friend because that think
outside the box and reacts quick and
warns you of danger and we know our
intuitive skills research shows are far
more accurate than when we have to try
and find logic and facts initially so
working with intuition as long as it's
functioning well is actually a massive
plus so you have to start joining forces
of two thinking brains and start working
together and again the research shows
the people who work with both the logic
and the intuition and learn how to
manage them and emotional warning
signals from the chimp system do the
best have you come across the work by
Byron Katy yeah yes yeah yeah I started
that that was that was one of the books
I started reading last night when I
couldn't sleep CU at this Tony Robins
event he was kind of talking about this
method um I thought actually find it
really helpful it's like these um these
four questions when you're having a
thought or or some kind of limiting
belief um question number one is this
true and then just asking yourself yes
or no like you know the the body will
have a response to that Yeah question
number two is this really true it's like
huh actually perhaps it's not and the
way that that that you know he was
talking about it at this this business
conference was a lot of us will um have
these limiting beliefs about what we can
or what we can't do and we'll say you
know in my case that oh you know I
shouldn't I can't grow my business
because if I do it'll mean my lifestyle
is going to is is going to become more
stressful like is that true is that
really true is like have I actually
examined all the evidence and like
landed at this conclusion that growing
business always means that the owner
becomes more
stressed and just writing it down and
asking those questions um and then you
know the next like question three would
be something like how does it make you
feel to identify with that thought and
then question four is how would it make
you feel if you just chose not to
identify with that thought yeah and then
you do like a a turnaround I think she
calls it where you sort
of write down the exact opposite of
which which in this context would be the
more the more my business grows the less
stressed I'll be yeah and you find
reasons to to support that and just like
a very simple stepbystep process where I
was like damn this is actually bloody
humle yeah and and you know it's a
really it's a sort of interesting um I
say variation of it's kind of CBT in
some ways that CBT will look at okay um
thought challenging so it's you know um
and that would be one way to do a
thought challenge is just ask yourself
is it true often when we're really stuck
with a thought and it's causing us a lot
of distress it's because we genuinely
buy into it and so you know once you get
to the point of therapy and you ask
someone is that thought true they will
say yes and and they do believe in it
and that's why they're in such pain and
so sometimes it's not enough and and
that's when you can go into the sort of
um challenging that thought so uh
looking at the evidence so is it true
okay let's let's just play around with
the idea of taking it to court and and
what where is the evidence not only in
my opinions but what evidence with up in
court to say this is true and then
looking at the other side where's the
evidence that it might not be true or
might not be the best reflection of
reality right now and you can go into
doing all that kind of thought
challenging stuff looking at both sides
getting really honest with yourself
about it and you can get help with like
um from friends and stuff to do that if
you're not in therapy um because
sometimes it's really difficult when
you're really stuck on something to even
consider other options and that's why
you're stu right cuz it's not easy um
but for some people that's not the best
way because it can set up an argument in
your mind and then you're just
ruminating on you know so you can kind
of try and go down for the you the all
the evidence that this thought isn't
true and then your mind just keeps
coming back with yeah but yeah but this
is the reason it's true this is the
reason it's true and you end up almost
in more distress because you're just
going back and forth with this sort of
internal argument um and that's when
the ACT stuff is super helpful so the
diffusion stuff so it's like actually do
you know what true or not I'm just going
to push this sort to there Y and I'm
just going to see it for what it is for
a minute and I'm going to try and hold
it
lightly and I know that that's one
option I can go down that and I can I
can go down that route and I can kind of
fuse with that thought and I can spend
time with it where is that going to take
me and what are my other options and and
sort of holding those options
lightly um
which is in some ways a bit more mindful
so rather than getting into the
nitty-gritty and and trying to find the
truth it's acknowledging that often a
truth is a mixture of different opinions
and not one and you're you know
sometimes you're never going to find the
truth yeah um and being okay with that
kind of holding that lightly and moving
on to the next
experience yeah one of the things I find
helpful is that
um almost almost the the that there is
no truth it's just you know generally if
I think of
the the disempowering thoughts that I
have they're not things that are like
objectively true or not it's not like
I'm I'm not going to be ruminating by
the fact that I cannot physically bench
200 kg but I might be thinking oh my
content is not valuable people don't
like me um I'm going to become
irrelevant like Oh I'm a bad public
speaker or whatever whatever the thing
might be but these things like you know
I was I speaking to my cousin the other
day in the car and she just casually
threw out the phrase oh I'm just really
lazy and I was like are you is that you
know is that true and she never really
questioned that belief because I guess a
belief is just a thought that we I that
that we hold with some level of
certainty and we sort of went went over
the evidence a little bit I was like I
don't know I mean to me it doesn't look
like you're lazy cuz you're doing this
this this and this like how how do you
feel about that she was like oh yeah I
mean I guess when you put it that way
you know perhaps I'm not lazy and it was
it was such it was almost a ration for
her to be like Oh I'm not actually lazy
oh like I've been telling myself
the story for such a long time but I
find it helpful to imagine the idea that
there is no truth it's just a matter of
a thought that we believe because we
have certainty with it yeah and actually
there are way way more options out there
than believing that one specific thought
that I'm lazy or I'm a bad public
speaker or whatever the thing might be
and that's where labeling thoughts can
be really helpful too so you know
noticing a thought for what it is is
often you know with that situation it's
as you have the thought
recognizing that's a judgment or that's
a self-criticism or that's an opinion or
that's a memory or that's a story I tell
myself or that's a prediction about the
future or there's a catastrophizing
thought so you know there are lots of
different types of
thoughts none of which would qualify for
giving fact as it is so as soon as you
can kind of notice a you know be mindful
of a thought notice it and then label it
as oh yeah that's a you know
self-critical Judgment of mine then then
you're in a better position to be able
to um take it for what it is and and not
buy into it you still might hold it
there and you still might feel like
you're lazy but noticing that it's an
unkind way of speaking to yourself and
an unhelpful kind of thought pattern or
an opinion
um helps you to kind of helps it to
carry less weight yeah and have less
effect on how you feel yeah like you're
holding it at arms length again yeah so
it's it's almost like this idea like
thought like labeling labeling this as a
narrative or as a story or as a memory
or as a self-criticism helps helps it
sort of be like oh actually it's just
that wooden mask yeah that I can hold a
little bit away from well it sounds like
you did a really great sort of thought
challenging exercise with her so done
you I've mentioned in the past a
personal success system what is what is
a personal success system system I think
everyone on the planet has a personal
success system they just might not know
exactly what it is and some friends who
popped in mind are the friend called
Shona who has a business called perfect
English grammar and her personal success
system is going to events because what
she finds is that every single time she
goes to an event she'll meet someone
she'll get an idea she'll she'll
something will happen and in the six
months after business doubles and that's
happened like three times now so because
she knows what it is what her personal
success system is she can apply this
going forward and she can just go to
bigger and better events and she can she
can kind of take the cruxs of this
system and just keep applying it and
everyone's second favorite billionaire
Jeff Bezos has a very similar thing
where he he will think of an idea he
will write a one-page press release
about it he will see how that goes down
with a very small group of people and
then he'll just build it and then he
knows that a few of them are going to
take off some of them aren't Amazon's
got like 157 businesses that it's
started that didn't go anywhere like you
remember the dash buttons and the um and
the fire phone and like random stuff and
it's like yeah we'll give it a go might
work might not that's like his success
system is coming up with the idea
writing the press release releasing it
and seeing what happens and I realized
that I had one too where if I look back
at anything that I'm like proud of or
anything I've achieved I pretty much
followed the exact same system to
achieve it and so this is going to be
different for everyone but mine is set
the intention speak to someone who's
done it ask them how they did it find
out a method and then split that method
into something that I do every single
day for about half an hour and just keep
going until it happens that's just
that's just my success system and so
when I worked this out I was like I need
to test this with other things so the
next next thing I had in mind was to
write a book and get a publisher so I
followed the exact same process and it
just worked and there's almost something
in like when you figure out what your
unique resources are what your unfair
advantages what your like somehow
weirdly placed to do with your resources
or the things around you you can figure
it out and then apply it going forward
and I think you can kind of achieve
anything so I don't know if you know
what yours is
like the top three like the top one
thing that you've
ever achieved that you're just super
proud of it probably had a method from
the start to the finish of how you got
there H as you were saying that I was
thinking about the very first cohort of
our YouTuber Academy which was like the
first product we released and just
completely exploded the business
overnight basically and that was I had
the idea while I was sitting in a
Starbucks in Cambridge
journaling in a physical pen and paper I
was like this would be a good idea
banged it out over the next several
weeks Non-Stop and then three weeks
later the course was live and made 3
350k and that was more money than I'd
ever seen before in my life have you
replicated that since with other things
I remember the first business I started
that was successful again zero to MVP in
about 3 weeks I had the idea while I was
at the mosque of like let me build a
company that sells medical admissions
courses and boom we were up and
accepting payments within 3 weeks
because I was just like I was like cool
I'm just going to do think not
overthinking it not worrying too much
about what people will think and just
having that sort of iterative kind of
mentality so the initial idea comes from
you not being in front of your
laptop yes that's very true the initial
idea comes from you having the space
being somewhere different having a pen
and paper Y and then after that what
made with each of those ideas did you
have the conviction that they would work
straight away I had the conviction that
it might work MH and so it was like a
lot of this could work let's just give
it a go how many of the ideas that you
write down in your Journal do you think
oh that won't work I'm not going to do
that one quite a lot so there's
something about those ones that made you
think this is worth doing yes so I'd I'd
find almost the metrics around that
because that's probably a system as well
you've probably got like all the ones
that I've written down that I've found
out or that I've thought would work had
these characteristics that they probably
all got in common and then the next
thing you did
was banged it out over the next few
weeks with a team I'm guessing that
probably followed the exact same process
as well solo initially and then the
second one was with a team of just like
all right Scrappy let's just bang stuff
together let's not overthink it let's
just whack it up you know and in both
cases and actually I think in in all
cases I got my hands quite dirty with it
it wasn't like uh I'll just sketch out
the vision and let the team execute it
was like I'm in making the landing pages
myself and doing the copywriting myself
okay and like in the nuts and bols of it
so getting Scrappy boots on the ground
taking imperfect action and then
launching yeah and then current current
Network current audience yeah just put
and I mean the first time around I
didn't have an audience so I had to post
on the student room and hope for the
best second time around I had Twitter
yes and so Twitter was where I was and
sort of building it in public as well
second time around so this is your
system this is exactly your system
coffee shop idea set of criteria that it
matches
taking Scrappy action and then just
doing it you could apply this to
anything going forward your next thing
that you want to achieve yeah this is
the thing so it's like I I'm I'm also
thinking you know when I was writing the
book most of the progress was made in
like very short births of time there was
this week where we were at a team
retreat in whales and some nice Airbnb
and I was like cool my job for this
whole week is just write one chapter a
day MH and from morning to evening I was
just like I'm just going to write the
chapter and I wrote like 50,000 words
that week yeah and I've never like
that's by far the most productive have
I've ever been in my life in terms of
like word count whereas it took like 2
years to write 10,000 because I was just
like overthinking and outline all this
sort of stuff I wonder if some kind of
magic source that works for you is this
taking away the pressure of it being
good and being okay with it being like
this is a disgusting first draft but
like it doesn't matter because it's
going to be like it's going to be fine
cuz you there's probably something in
there that means you trust where it's
going to go so you will accept a level
of imperfection because you know it's
kind of part of the story but you know I
quite like to think about like the movie
of your life like if this was a movie of
your life right now then you there in
your cabin in Wales writing the book
like that would be there and it would be
a really fun scene and it would be like
there's like rain outside and there's
like sheep barring in the distance and
it's like it's this glorious kind of
thing and you're there like and like
scrunching it up and going like that and
like it would be cool it would be so
there's may be something that's like you
know it's part of the story you know
it's ultimately going to lead to success
that lets you kind of get out of your
own way and just put words on the paper
which is powerful because loads of
people can't do that because of the
writers block
thing yeah I think recently we've not
followed the system because we now have
a head of product who's responsible like
you know been wanting to make a
productivity course for a while if i'
followed the system I would have just
like banged it out in three weeks and it
would be done yeah but now we're like
well we've got to have of product and we
should like we've got a big audience now
it's kind of a big deal we should do
this properly and therefore we should do
the competitor analysis and we should
figure out what the offer is and we
should follow the methods and yeah all
this kind of stuff and I can see the
value in that but I'm also kind of like
feeling feeling the sense of like I just
want to make it in a weekend yeah cuz I
think I can make it in a weekend rather
than a six-month period of like back and
forth with with our head of product I
think it's a really valid point and I
think it's almost why startups will
always do well because they don't have
this sense of oh we need to do it
properly whereas like businesses that
have been going a very long time they've
got like policy and HR and procedures
and stuff they have to do so they almost
they almost become irrelevant because
they are following so many different
procedures when the startups are like
we're just going to do we're just going
to execute we're going to get on with it
so maybe getting back to the the
scrappier the scrappier you might be the
way so I guess just thinking about this
out loud I could do the scrappy version
0.1 soft launch it to like Twitter in
the email list see what
happens and then at that point I lose
interest in it and then I can head it
over to a team team member to take it
from 0.1 to like 100 yeah because you're
the Visionary yeah are you an e and TJ
uh yeah yes yeah we're the same but yeah
that's exactly it the the e means you're
super extrovert the N means the it's
like the Visionary the I've got these
great ideas but then you need someone
else to go and and the t means very very
logical the J means that you can plan it
all out but ultimately you don't even
though you know what the plan should be
you don't want to execute the plan so
that's where yeah team comes in and goes
hey there's all these cool stuff cool
things in mind and they do it sick so
how how would someone go about finding
their own personal success
system think about the things that
you've done that you're most proud of
and not the things that you think you
should be the most proud of but the
things you're really secretly the most
proud of and then figure out what you
did from start to finish to make them
happen and do that with multiple things
and then find patterns whatever they are
however weird the patterns are it might
be that everything that you've ever
achieved on a on a really cool level has
always involved this one person or has
always involved this one coffee shop in
Cambridge or whatever it might be find
those patterns and then go to those
people go to those places again and try
and replicate it so let's say I
am studying architecture at University
and I'm thinking you know I I want to
actually be an architect I don't want to
be one of those you know architect
dropouts that start a YouTube channel
for now I want to study architecture I
want to build my professional reputation
I want to network with the right people
maybe I'm active on on Linkin maybe I'm
going to these conferences and just
trying to build up a decent body of work
but I'm also thinking in the back of my
mind you know I can see myself based on
the sort of person I am you know back
when I was in school I was selling candy
bars whatever um I'm thinking maybe I
want to start my own firm one day and
preferably sooner rather than later once
I've got a bit of experience under my
belt and hm maybe this personal brand
stuff could be interesting in that
position let's say someone is a
professional in a traditional career and
they like the idea of a person
brand firstly what's what's the benefit
of them trying to build a personal brand
within a professional industry and then
how would they go about it well I mean
obviously it will give you options
further down the line that's you know
that's a big you know a big benefit for
sure um in terms of going ahead and
actually starting it and doing it I
would be in this day and age I'd be
really really upfront with my boss and
I'd say hey I'm thinking of starting a
YouTube channel where uh I'm going to
show people how to draw what how to use
CAD or how to make 3D models or whatever
it is that people do in architecture you
know offices and my father was an
architect so I've kind of grown up
around that a little bit um and uh I
just thought before I start doing it I'm
not going to mention my company that I'm
working for or anything like that
opinions are my own and all that sort of
stuff but would you have a problem with
it or not because you're better off
being upfront with that and getting the
green light from your boss then you
would do putting an entire year into it
the boss is not liking it and then
getting into trouble that wouldn't be a
good situation to be in at all but it
would certainly give you opportunities
further down the line it creates options
which is never a bad thing at all you
know but Ally honestly you know we're
sitting here talking about this if you'd
have told me you know 17 18 years ago
when I opened the doors to my first
business that I would be writing a
bestselling book on building a personal
brand business that I would be making
money to speak in front of complete
strangers on on stages around the world
um and have you know tens of thousands
of people tuning into my show every week
like I would not have seen this coming
at
all this has not been planned or at
least initially it wasn't right I'd like
to think that I've been a little bit
more strategic in the last seven or
eight years but at least at first like I
didn't even realize I had a personal
brand until I got my first book deal and
then I realized it was one one
particular conversation that I had with
the Publishers uh who said my first book
was called virtual freedom and they said
that they liked the concept of the book
and the proposal for the book because it
felt like it was the Outsourcing life
section of the 4-Hour Work week that
never got printed kind of thing it was
like the next step kind of thing um and
that's great and that's going to put you
on another pedestal Chris and I was like
well okay that's great and everything
but I'm not really I don't really I just
want to help people like I'm not I'm not
writing this book to go on to you know
to move up a pedestal too like this is
just what I've gone through in the last
four five six years I burned out in 20
2009 and then had to come back from that
and part of that process was hiring a
whole bunch of people to replace myself
some virtual some not but then you know
I started blogging and podcasting and
all that sort of stuff in 2010 about vas
and virtual teams and all of a sudden
BOS I'm getting a publishing deal
because I'm the VA
guy right so okay great I've always
wanted to become a public a published
author that's a goal that you know let's
take that off uh you know the the the
list and we'll move on from that but
then what happened was after the book
came out people started to say to me how
did you do that how did you get the book
deal and I started reverse engineering
it back and I said I got the book deal
because I was publishing content three
times a week on my blog and I was
podcasting every week and you know I was
doing YouTube videos every now and then
I was was on Twitter you know back when
you know Twitter was like really cool
when it first started right and all this
sort of stuff and reverse engineer back
you realize actually I'm building that
personal brand up over a period of time
and it just ended up culminating with a
book deal so then that's where upo was
born that was where if I can do it for
nothing there's no reason why I can't
help other people do it as well and that
that was where EO was born is there is
is there a way to build a personal brand
without I guess quote creating content
or is that really the main lever I mean
I think there probably is uh I I don't
think you need to you know one of the
one of the easiest ways for us to spread
our message our opinions our
ideas and our thoughts today is doing
exactly what we're doing right now it's
getting in front of other PE other
people's audiences right um and know
your people will tune in and I'm a
little m
right I people either like me or they
don't like me there's not a lot of messy
Middle with me and I'm actually fine
with that as well I think pretty much
every content creator should be like
that you know you either love it or hate
it like M might have it they've got it
down right in terms of marketing like
they lean into that love it or ha it
things so well and it works brilliantly
and I think the same could be said for
personal Brands as well but this was not
something that I really thought was
going to happen but now I've just rolled
into it and I think that the majority of
people people who jump on board with the
idea of building a personal brand um and
they understand the power of it and
there is a certain amount of
responsibility involved as well
obviously as you get more and more known
and respected uh your opinions and what
you say online really matter
particularly but no I I don't think you
need to create content yourself but I
think in today's world you definitely
need to
be you need to be in front of other
people their other people's content
maybe you've had a bunch of setbacks in
your career with like injuries and
things like that and I know that you
know anyone listening to this or
watching this will have also
experienced major or minor setbacks in
their life where they've maybe had a
goal or a vision or a purpose to work
towards and then the universe has
dropped a piano on them and like
something is something bad has
happened in I guess in your world you
know the the world of of of elite high
performance what are some strategies
that you and your team have found
helpful for dealing with dealing with
setbacks yeah it's it's hugely important
particularly in in today's you know
today's world you need to understand we
don't live in a a a perfect world
there's going to be disappointments
there's going to be setbacks you're not
going to achieve every single goal you
set out to achieve but having the right
tools to to deal with those situations
can be a huge Advantage give you so much
motivation give you real strength and
desire to um you know to to learn from
those learn from those moments so a lot
of people look at my career and just
focus on the success but I firmly
believe the person that I am today it's
not because of the trophies that I've
won or the the accolades that I get it's
it's because of the the difficult times
the
setbacks that I've had and that you know
the things that not many people sort of
know or or learn about and that's what I
you know wanted to to share in the
chapter and my book around resilience
and having the right tools to deal with
resilience so there
amazing um you know story that that I
tell that I used to hate to talk about
because it was at the 2011 Rugby World
Cup where we went on to win it um and
I'd been the vice captain of the team
for three years behind the great Richie
mcco but I'd never Captain the All
Blacks um whenever he wouldn't play I
wouldn't play for whatever reason but in
the last round Robbin game of the Rugby
World Cup in New Zeal Zealand I got the
phone call the day before the game The
Last Round Robin game to Captain the All
Blacks one of the best uh phone calls
that that I've had and of course I said
yes Richie mcco pulled out late with a
little niggling injury and here I was
really proud moment uh to to Captain the
All Blacks for the first time so I went
off to the the press conference day
before the game uh to talk to the media
about how proud I was to finally Captain
the old blacks what a special moment it
was for my family and I went off to our
final training run uh which is called
the captain's run which is the captain
gets to the side what you do this is
quite a proud moment this is feeling
good it's been a great day for me uh we
went through the captain's run I always
finished the captain's run with a few
shots at goal um and I've been kicking
goals ever since I could walk dad taught
me to kick with both feet as soon as I
could walk so I've kicked millions of
kicks in my life my last shot at goal I
was lining up the kick and as I came
into kick and the impact of the my boot
hitting the ball I dropped to the ground
and I had a serious injury and my groin
had just um actually torn off my pubic
bone and I just fell to the ground in
extreme Agony and this is my third world
cup and I'd had two fa World Cups we'
done so much work around the psychology
we I just felt like we were destined to
finally win a World Cup I was 28 I was
in the prime of my career everything was
so well I thought this is my time this
is my moment and and then for it to all
be taken away by such a serious injury I
was I was devastated so I rushed off to
the uh the the Medical Center where I
had scans so I was with my my doctor and
and then the specialist my doctor like
do you want to see the results and I was
like no I knew in my mind that my dream
was over this is and I'm a firm believer
that things happened for a reason but
this was going to be my last last World
Cup and all those thoughts of why me why
now why such a serious injury nothing
made sense in my mind at all everything
had just been taken away from me I
jumped in the car to go back to the
hotel um and halfway on the Journey Back
to the Hotel I hey Doc you know is my
world cup dream over and she's like yes
and I just burst into tears I cried all
the way back to the hotel went to my
room you know players would come through
coaches would come through to but they
couldn't say anything there's nothing
that they could say could change this
and it was just like dead silence every
time uh someone came in you know it was
it was nice to know that they were
thinking of me and make the effort to
come and and that helped but I was
distraught so I was I was angry I was
sad I was you know disappointed at all
the emotions you know running through my
body and um but then you know after a
couple of days I was like hold on like
you know what does an all black great do
in situations like this so my purpose
really helped me through uh through this
the setback what does nor black great do
that's right nor black great rehabs this
injury better than anyone's rehab this
injury before an all black great um
resets goals you know you said that an
all black great needs to play for 10
years or longer so I signed a new
contract to play for another four years
in New Zealand um to get me through to
another world World Cup um and also an
all black great puts the team first so
what does the team need me to do now or
I'm injured so I need to help the player
plan in my position he went on to get
injured as well so they brought in
another player so I had to help him he
got injured went to a four string number
10 and it's a great story cuz um the
four string number 10 went on to kick
the winning goal in the World Cup final
but through that process there was some
great tools and learnings to to help me
deal with resilience the first one was
the importance to to grief so far too
often I see people have a really setback
disappointment and they just they move
on really positive ah it's not that
important not it's not that important H
actually right no no really positive
minding straight away and I've seen that
it you know bites them in the ass
further down the track cuz they don't
deal with your emotions straight away so
it's important to grieve deal with your
emotions
so much so that when I have an injury my
wife knows to stay away from me for 24
hours cuz I'm not a nice person to be
around I'm grumpy I'm angry I'm just
dealing processing it all but there
needs to be you need to flick the switch
at some stage so for me it was 24 hours
and with depending on the the severity
of the sitb back it can be a little bit
longer there's no point me moping around
the hotel room for the next 2 weeks
feeling sorry for myself so I do that
for 24 hours I flick the switch that's
when I change my mindset into a positive
one okay what are the the goals that I
want to to set now that I've injured
whether it's your rehab or longer term
of uh in four years time so I reset my
goals so that's another really important
thing of of dealing dealing with a
setback um so it's that's really helped
me and I had this new motivation to to
bounce back uh from from the inury yeah
uh 2012 I got named 12 months later you
know World rugby player of the year so I
I returned and had a fantastic year 2015
rby World Cup was one of my sort of best
uh Rugby World Cups that I ever played
you know sort of man of the match
performance the Rugby World Cup final I
was able to bounce back all of a
sudden four years earlier
when things weren't making any sense
they all made sense now um all those
moments and setbacks were built up to
make me a stronger more motivated
um player in in 2015 so I kind of sit
across from you today knowing that uh
you know the person that I am today a
lot more sort of resilient and have the
tools to help deal with with resilience
is is uh because of of those setbacks
that that I had through my career I have
this pet theory that we are looking at
speaking the wrong way
around and that if you are someone who
is let's let's take the example of
someone shy and let's say you're at a
drinks and you're sitting on the sofa
and there's people around you and
they're all chatting to each other and
no one's chying to
you and you start to have these thoughts
that maybe like I'm not interesting and
someone tries to talk to you and the
conversation doesn't really go anywhere
for whatever reason they get distracted
or you know you feel like they're
turning
away in that moment it's very easy to
think okay I'm going to get better at
speaking and the way I'm going to do
that is I'm going to be so charming and
charismatic I'm going to learn how to
sit up straight I'm going to learn how
to uh use posture use hands tell stories
be exciting uh get rid of my arms and rs
I'm going to change all of these outside
tips and tricks and then when I have
that I'll be good at speaking and then
everyone and then I'll be confident
enough to speak up at my drinks and it's
kind of this outside in approach only
when I have learned all these tips and
tricks will I be good enough to talk to
people and right now the reason I'm not
good enough is because I don't know how
to do these things I don't have those
skills and I think that's the wrong way
around I think it's the opposite I think
that in
reality I heard this I heard this phrase
and um I quite like it the problem is
not the
problem the problem is your solution to
the
problem nice so the problem here is not
your inability to speak or your speaking
ability the problem here is you thinking
you are a bad
speaker or you thinking that other
people are judging you and so therefore
you protect yourself by not
speaking by staying
quiet and that is the
problem and so in reality rather than
fixing it from the outside in of like if
I do all these tips and tricks then
finally on the inside I'll be good
enough the reality is that on the inside
you are good
enough when you speak to your close
friends to your family to your loved
ones in some
situations you're totally free I think
everyone has those places where they're
they're totally free and they can speak
but then in this situation you're
not so instead of learning speaking from
the outside in of like these are the
skills I need to learn and then I'll be
confident we should learn it from the
inside out I am the way me the way I am
right now knows how to
speak and if I just unlearn all of those
beliefs I have about myself about being
terrible and and having no
value then I'll be able then I'll be
amazing all right so that's it for this
week's episode of Deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are going to be linked down
in the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye